it's my pleasure to introduce Professor
Ellen G who's the Walter B Reinhold
professor in the School of Engineering
as well as the Robert Bosch chair of
mechanical engineering here at Stanford
so she's passionate about understand
about improving human health uh through
through computational simulation her
expertise is in living matter physics
which is the use of theoretical and
computational models to simulate and
predict the behavior of living matter so
we're going to learn a lot more about
that in a second and one one thing that
was interesting in your bio kind of a
subset of that is you're also a founding
member of the living Heart Project which
is a translational project that's aiming
to revolutionize cardiovascular science
through the use of realistic simulations
of the human
heart and so in addition to that I
should also add that she is also quite
an athlete so you are a a three-time
qualifier for the Kona Iron Man champ
world world championship as well as a
three-time All-American triathlete and a
marathon runner including the B Boston
and New York Marathon so what you do as
an athlete in your spare time most of us
would do as our full-time job but we're
super excited to have you here today to
learn a little bit more about um this
idea of automated model Discovery and
how that's revolutionizing science right
now so I think a great place to start
would be if you could just give us a
little bit more about your background
and in particular the living matter lab
and what you're researching and doing
yeah sure yeah thanks than for having me
so um yeah so in the living matter lab
what we do is um we design physics-based
tools that we embed in machine learning
and then we model living systems as you
just said and you mentioned the heart so
we're doing this for the heart we do
this also for arteries for the lung for
muscle and then most recently what
people find most interesting is the
brain
um and we work a lot uh here at Sanford
with people in the clinic um people who
design or use devices for instance heart
valves that go into the heart um kind of
to help them design a therapy that's
targeted for a certain person and then
uh because I'm an engineer it's always
centers around forces and stresses to
really understand the forces in the
heart that these devices change and so
could you give us a little bit more
about I mean obviously a part of that is
modeling how the heart works so how
we're going to get into the autom
uh automated model Discovery a second
but how were you know what's one special
about soft matter versus say modeling
something like a steel or a metal and
how was that done in the past yeah
that's a great point so the way people
have done this in the past I mean people
have modded materials like for a century
probably and they've always gone and
tested it and then they fit some data
points to a curve and that was their
model and so a lot of people have
attached their name to a certain model
so you probably know the hope spring um
there's for rubber there's the ogan
rubber model or the Mooney Rhythm model
and so people have just attached the
name and now years later you can just go
to a library of models and say I want to
use the H uper model which is developed
by H uper and so now you just go through
this library of a 100 different models
and then you fit your material to that
one model that you like um and that's
important because uh then you can test
you can use the model and hopefully also
predict what it would do in other other
settings right and how are those so how
do you go about selecting that model is
that require that you have an expertise
and I what level of expertise or yeah
how does that happen do you need I think
you're hitting the critical part here
and that's really finding a good model
and so in the past people were just
selecting one of this big library of
models and they would just go in and
find the one that they think is good and
to do that right you would probably have
to read a lot of books on material
modeling or take classes in continum
mechanics finite elements as a student
or read up on it in in manuals of of
textbooks it was really uh limited to
experts in the field and I think what
what we found really tricky when I teach
students is to teach them to use the
right model and select the best model
because it really requires experience
and it limits the use of these tools to
really people who are super well trained
in it right and so what we thought is
can we automate that process and make
that more available to broader usership
of people when I work with someone in
the hospital they are not experts in
mechanic or physics they haven't taken
these classes and still they want to
model something can we make it safe for
them to use these and so that leads us
maybe to automated model discovery which
is kind of the focus here so can you
talk about a little bit about what this
process is and how it's different from
that Old process of someone created a
model and then you go into a library of
of potential models and you select one
uh and then apply apply it to your
situation yeah and that's the great
question is can we automate that process
can we make take the user out of this
equation of selecting and actually make
it less prone to error right um and so
we have what we have done and actually
it's a very new method that people have
started to develop over the last two
three four years is they use neural
networks uh to help select the model and
so then you kind of feed the information
that you have into the network and use
networks of traditional devel develop
for just other things I mean they're
very powerful tools for image
recognition for example but now tweak
that and use it for
Discovery okay and then so can we back
up so you said model Discovery so it's
model Discovery and is at the same time
sort of selecting so can you walk
through it one more time like how that
would work so I'm say I'm a hospital say
I I'm a doctor or something who does not
have a background how would I how would
I apply this or how would I use this
would I have I would have a set of data
or I would have a situation I want to
apply it too and can you walk me through
that a little so ideally you would have
data but data meaning for example if we
model say the heart there would be tests
and ideally they different tests so you
can do like tension compression share
twist test on little samples of heart
tissue and then you just feed that
information into the neural network uh
if you don't have that now I'm assuming
you don't have that at hand uh we have a
website where we have collected um
databases for heart for cardiovascular
tissue brain tissue rubber just so that
you can get started and play with it and
then that gets fed into the network as
pretty much the input to the network the
network does run and then it gives you a
model and it gives you model param as
can uh so you talked earlier about sort
of Designing something for a particular
heart I mean does this work in terms
of is there a difference between
modeling hearts in general and using
this to model a particular heart is
there is there ability to sort of
personalize the the the model that
you're using to fit the person that
you're developing in something for so um
depends on what kind of tissue you want
in this case you probably don't want to
give me piece of your heart today um but
in general yeah so some pieces of tissue
you can just Harvest from a person and
test and people do that or you would
have an age group selection down the
road where you say okay this is a 50y
old male has this kind of healthy heart
conditions and we have a library for
that we're just starting to build these
things but that's a great question uh
the question is how much does it differ
and I would say probably in a healthy
person it differs by some magnitude but
not too much so you could probably live
with someone else's data other so if you
already have the data Library what
um it what would be creating the
different what are you adjusting to
create a different model what's uh so so
right now we're at the process of
developing this method for General thing
okay so when we have a a data library on
the heart we could run it through and
develop discover the best model um why
is this different from what people have
done so what people have done is they
have just used the model they have
fitted um but that's probably hundreds
of models and you don't know it's the
best okay um also what we do is we
combine different models so the network
you can think of a neural network having
a a number of different nodes say about
20 so the model can discover two to the
power of 20 so that's 100 thousand or
more a million different models okay
because it can combine different and and
mix and match different terms and so we
have done this and tried this and
actually sometimes we discover models
that already others have used which is
nice because out of this 50,000 models
you discover the whole model which is
great um but sometimes you don't and
then you ask yourself okay would people
have found this with any other way
probably not right because you wouldn't
screen 50,000 different models by hand
and so this is actually great because
you have this vast overview and library
of things you can choose from that's
interesting um and so neural networks
have been around well for a fairly long
time but there's something unique about
the way you're doing this and it's I'm
going to read it here because it's
called constitutive neural networks so
what are constitutive neural networks
and how are they what was the challenge
with the traditional neural network and
how did the constitutive neural networks
address those challenges um that's a
great point because you could
technically go ahead and just use a
neuron Network to do this right you
would take a neural network off the
shelf feed in your data neural networks
are great at fitting functions actually
with any number of these noes they could
approximate any function to any degree
of accuracy that's just that's just a
proof to show this but we want to build
a specific function and we don't want to
use it for something like image
recognition where it is very good off
the shelf but we want to build physics
into the network and we know the physics
so for example we know when we pull on
something that usually um and this is
say an artery it gets harder over time
to pull so it's kind of like having this
exponential stiffening behavior and we
want to kind of build that information
in and we also want to build in that in
physics if you measure forces over
deformation or stress over restrain we
kind of have a curve and not a zigzag
and all that is in a way built in in in
the network so we hard bu our physics
into the design into the input into the
output into the architecture of the
network itself and into the activation
functions and after we've done this you
as a user don't need to worry about it
so this network that we have
automatically now satisfies all the
physics and this is a trend that has
been around for the last five or maybe
10 years for for constitutive moders for
we only three okay um and it's
constraining this huge space of
functions that a neural network would
searge over there putting sort of rails
around guidelines around it so you're
not getting something that violates the
laws of physics and then you come with
something that actually you know already
our priority that it satisfies
everything and are those are those what
your and this is sorry I'm a I'm not
technical so my my question would be the
guidelines or constraints that you're
putting in around it the physics are
those models themselves or are they is
there does that make sense is there are
you kind of putting having it having the
model develop in relationship to
existing to what how we model certain
things like stretching of arteries yeah
yeah so for example we can say um
there's a certain symmetry to the
material so it's the same from every
direction that you look at it we can
build that in or you can build into it
that when you loaded and unloading
loaded it behaves the same way so it's
plastic um and certain things you can
just hardwire in and then also we want
to make sure that all these existing
models that people have developed are a
subpart of this so this is a natural
General generalization of what people
have done but much much broader you can
think of a couple of thousand models in
in this one network and we had a
question so I do want to get to this we
had a question earlier come in about
using these models I mean is this
something that's only being run at
Stanford with you know like high
performance Computing or super computers
or is this something that someone can do
at at home or at a hospital or with more
modest resources yeah yeah I mean we run
this on on laptop just like this um we
have all the software on a GitHub um
repository from our lab so you can find
this on our website you can just link it
uh and also what's super cool and what
I'm most excited about is if you want to
use this a lot of people use this for
what's called finite element simulation
so they want to model real structures
okay like the real heart and so we've
teamed up with the salt Sy stem which is
a company that actually has one of the
largest fin packages called Abacus and
what they do is they use our output of
the network to really use it immediately
feed that into that simulation so
there's like a direct handshape between
what the model produces and what the uh
finite element simulation can take in as
input and this is very general so what
this is one example you can just already
download it from our website but you can
also translate that into any other
package so the idea is it's not just a
stand alone but it feeds immediately
into a simulation that anybody wants to
do with like a larger structure and I I
have a f we have a good question about
kind of the applications of this but
before we maybe jump into that what one
other thing that I I read about these is
that there is so one of the concerns
about a lot of algorithms or neural
networks is they're black boxes it's
very hard right you get an output you
don't know how it's getting there my
understanding is the constitutive neural
networks as opposed that are a little
bit more interpretable it's you you're
able to understand the model can you you
mentioned that already but could you
maybe elaborate on that yeah thanks for
actually bringing this up because that's
true so a lot of times when you just run
a neural network you get some bit of a
curve but nothing more than that and so
here you really get some information
about say the stiffness so it gives you
parameters that have a unit of a
stiffness or a sheer modulus or person
Ratio or just common physics parameters
and also interpretable terms so you have
have a term that's linear where you see
in the curve it's linear and then
overlaid a quadratic function and one
can be related say to the Matrix
material of the tissue and one can be
related to collagen fibers you can
really interpret the terms and the the
parameters that are otherwise just
Network blackbox parameters really have
a physical meaning so they're real
physics parameters and so does that give
uh I mean especially if you're using
this for developing medical devices that
give you more confidence in the accuracy
of the models or does it what does it
you know can you build on what it means
for it to be more interpretable it's a
lot more helpful so because there's this
vast body of literature where people
have done studies in the past so you can
compare for instance we now now put some
data into the network you to say oh this
Compares well to a healthy artery or
this looks more like a diseased artery
or something right so you kind of have a
great base of comparison people and
exactly I think this is a criticism from
a lot of people in physics or in our
case engineering that um neural networks
don't use any of our prior knowledge and
for decades Engineers have or physicist
mathematicians have really built tools
and an understanding and insight into
things and you don't want to just lose
that right um and and I'm just a quick
because we see we got a great question
about so the models are they open source
we there's a link in the interface to
the living matter lab and I believe
there you there's a link to the GitHub
repository so you can find a lot so if
anybody can't find that just reach out
and be happy to point you but uh all in
our GitHub and it's called GitHub living
metal app and so you find it there so if
you're interested in learning more about
it or or sort of playing with it well
and to that point what are some of the
applications or what are the things that
you're most excited about in terms of uh
Auto in terms of this process the
automated models so I can give you an
example of something that people have
previously not studied uh where this is
cool so over the summer we've with a a
bunch of undergraduates in our lab we
have tested a lot of artificial meat and
so there's the cool appli
because a lot of people claim that the
perception of taste is related to the
stiffness of the meat and so you think
about eat like super soft tofu and you
feel it doesn't taste right and it's not
a good meat replacement right and so the
idea is of these products to match the
mechanical signature of real meat and
that's not just the stiffness but also
the the fibrous aspect so it's usually
anisotropic it has a certain fibrous
structure that that tissue has from
because is muscle tissue mainly and so
um they try to recreate meat that has
the mechanics of real meat and nobody
has a mechanical model for artificial
meat so we're like oh we can disc
discover this with our Network and
actually works quite well so we just
have tested a bunch of like the entire
Supermarket
sh and and actually it was really cool
study because the students learned how
to use the device to use this new method
and we discovered some more that's
actually out of it so that was so that's
the future of dining we'll have a uh
we'll have a a texture an actual
mechanical texture rating for well the
real future would be like if we can
learn so much that we can design like
the best matching material right so what
this is doing is you you were testing
the meat and you're from that you were
creating a model of how that meat
behaved and that gave you parameters
that helped you sort of interpret it
ideally you would know what you're
saying ideally you would now go back and
say okay what do we have to change to
adjust certain properties of it like
when does it fail how stiff is it how
does it cheer right and what would so
this little off topic but what would
that look like would you have would you
then go back and say well what you would
I presumably now have a model of real
beef of real uh and and maybe even at
different stages of cooking I don't know
if yeah yeah yeah so I mean ideally if
you could put these parameters I mean we
haven't done all of this yet obviously
that would be great to have but um that
would be a cool thing to do and then
really have all these different
parameters that influence the the the
mechanics of it um and then the
perception of taste with that that's
really interesting um we so we have some
of these more questions about so it's
obviously one thing if you're testing a
sort of artificial meat what I mean
where are you seeing the applications in
something like healthcare and I'm
assuming we're still and what still
needs to be done because presumably
there's a long way from going from
modeling you know modeling the heart to
creating a or maybe not to creating an
actual so we've done this for example
for the brain so um brain is super soft
it's very difficult to test it was one
of the last materials that people really
got their hands on testing so you you
mentioned steel so there's this long
history where people initially started
testing very stiff materials because it
were simple they don't deform much
they're pretty linear um you could just
pretty much stably test them and then
the next thing was muscle and arteries
and then probably um or other softer
tissues gels and then the brain is the
softest of all biological tissues so
it's the last kind of thing that people
try to study you think of the football
players when they get a hit to the Head
what you want to do is you want to
translate the deformation or the
acceleration of the helmet into forces
and those forces you apply to the head
and then you can get a very high
resolution uh response in terms of a
stress profile and then you can even say
oh this region of the brain is most
affected by this head hit okay and that
region is responsible for motor motor
skills or language or Vision or whatever
and so you can correlate a h to the head
with a stress profile with a function
that's interesting and then that and
then in turn that might translate into
how you build a better helmet yeah or
safer devices or even diagnose things or
um in surgery if you have to cut the
brain which region is do you want to cut
in what's the safest region so there's a
lot of mechanics actually um when you
hit the head what what you can where you
can really apply these methods um Can
this so we're getting you know a
question about how about non-living
matters so non-soft materials is it can
this be applied to other kinds of
materials and and would there be
advantages over you know the traditional
methods or steel just understood well
enough that maybe this is so yeah so I
think many of the materials in their
operating range like steel are probably
relatively well understood materials
that are linear um are not difficult to
discover you measure two points and you
fit a line okay so it's kind of from a
scientific Point not that interesting
probably um but all kinds of gels rubber
materials like soft materials in general
um meta materials where people design
materials for certain functions so all
kinds of materials you can apply it in
general for everything um but these are
materials where it's probably most um
impactful should also say right now um
this is a new technology we're very
confident using it for elastic materials
so when you load them and unload them on
the same behavior they don't have any
permanent deformations or damage um Next
Step would be to take this into
something that's time dependent
temperature dependent the damage has
failed right and and you could take this
method Way Beyond what it's currently
doing so that's a huge potential to
actually explore and would that be in
collecting more data so say you're
you're testing a material right now at
room temperature would it be gathering
more data at different temperatures is
that I mean is there a point where that
could be worked into the constitutive
part of the conal network where where
the actual physics of how these behave
yeah I mean for instance temperature one
uh certain materials polymers become
glassy when it's at different
temperatures or change entirely their
state certain materials fail so for
saying biomaterials it's pretty
interesting to know when they fail when
how what much of a hit can the brain
tolerate it's not just in sports but in
car accidents in Battlefield right
there's a lot of this that you can
actually test and then try to understand
better or how do these uh um tissues
interact with devices how if you put a
very stiff device a pacing electrode
into the heart or stimulation into the
brain they're usually out of not like
the engineered materials matters very
stiff how does it interact with a soft
material bra uh and how does this work
for things like uh so we're getting a
question about like modeling blood flow
or something like that for for different
is that a totally diff is that kind of
on a physics level a totally different
thing to model or is that something that
could also eventually be tackled by this
approach um yeah so that's a fluid uh so
we did have done this so far for solids
mainly but I think you could potentially
also do this for fluids we have actually
one application that's just very recent
where we looked at how um Alzheimer
spreads through the brain so that's not
mechanics at all interesting and there
we tried to discover a model of the
spreading of alzheim is EAS brain based
on physics of um of spreading and and
growth of this um this disease and so
this was a similar thing where you fed
it data and then it it it developed a
model and then you could so in that case
it's maybe um essentially so it's then
revolutionizing how you understand
Alzheimer's or the spread of Alzheimer's
and would that I mean so does that
potentially lead to to treatments I mean
how would you in turn once you have a
sense of how it spreads how do you how
how does
that so it helps you understand the
timeline it helps you understand the
different regions in the brain that are
affected ideally of course want to
understand if they can halt it or revert
it or stop it right um the model itself
would probably not be able to tell you
that but it can give you a lot more
information about Regional which regions
are affected at which point of the
disease and how does that kind of affect
the behavior of the person the decline
in behavior um and that's very different
because you work with data that has been
collected in patients and people and
disease and not data that you create
yourself so there in a way you have a
lot of data but the data are not you
can't manipulate the data in the way you
get what you get yeah um we have so
going a little bit off topic or not off
topic but but taking a little bit of a
pivot here so there's a this question we
have an interesting question that came
up and kind of if you're testing a
single material like the brain but you
talked about modeling like a hit to the
head so of course at that point the
force is going through skin the skull so
how do I mean I I assume there are
traditional approaches to that does this
feed into it or you just you have
there's a model of the individual
materials and then an overall model of
how they interacted can you talk a
little bit more about that and whether
this could be used to model complicated
systems with different material yeah
absolutely so you can do this with
finite element so you would just take a
scan of your head and then you section
it and we've done that you section in
different regions so there would be the
skull that would be fluid there would be
the the brain itself there ventricles
that are fluid filled and so all of that
can have different properties you chop
it in little pieces and every p piece
you assign a certain material so you
would test the skin and the skull and
the Brain itself and then everything has
a different stiffness and then when you
hit it you can automatically see like
reflection waves at the interfaces of
certain materials usually there's stress
concentrations of two different material
so that's very interesting because
that's where some diseases happen
usually interesting and then is the
model that's coming out one that is a I
don't know what the word would be a
composite model of all those different
things or you have a a a a models of
each of them
yeah it's more each of those so you have
certain regions that have a different
material property in way you well that
we could go on as I'll say very but
we're we're running short so only 30
minutes I did want to talk a little bit
about the class that's a class you've
run before in the summer but you're
offering it this winter and it is open
to professional students if they're
interested in taking it online so you
can find more about that in the
interface there should be a link to the
class right there on the right hand
upper right hand side next to Professor
CO's biography so if you want to click
on that to learn learn more about it but
I would love to hear so what is what is
this class I mean what do you what do
you need to know so it sounds like you
don't need to be a physicist to take the
class but what would what is the class
what do you cover in the class so in the
class we pretty much cover what we just
talked about we go more in depth and so
we teach how these methods work uh we
give uh students access to all the code
which is online but we explain it we let
them run it they have a project where
they can use it for certain things it's
targeted obviously at students who are
interested in neural networks and
bringing physics and Engineering into
the network but it's also targeted if
you want as researchers post dogs who
want to use this to study their their
materials and understand that better or
discover new materials also probably
people from industry who want to design
finite element tools um and use this to
have a very specific material model
someone who probably doesn't have that
skill set um and comes in and doesn't
want to take years and years of classes
so I Envision that down the road this
class will probably replace all these
glasses like continer mechanics fin
modeling solid mechanics because this
all automated at some point and the
theory is built into the network right
interesting well maybe not replaceable a
fewer people maybe we we'll take those
this will be it'll be another path um
and so but it sounds like there's a
broad application then there are both
people who want to who who are maybe
have taken those classes and are or have
the the the training in the background
and want to develop new models and also
people who want to use the models who
don't have that background and want to
apply it so that's really interesting um
well we're just about at time and so I
appreciate all of you joining us today
and for your questions I know we only
got to a handful but you have the
opportunity either to go to Professor
CO's lab again there should be a link
right there should be three resource
links it's right at the top the living
matter lab all the code is available
there uh through through GitHub as well
as some of the papers talking about the
applications in more detail um and then
we uh
and if you're still interested you're
you're welcome to join uh the course if
you want to get a deep dive and so that
will be offered through Stanford online
it is a uh you can click on the link to
learn more about it it'll be offered
this winter quarter I should warnant it
is a graduate level course right so it
will require it is a intensive course
it's probably 10 to 15 hours of work or
something a week it's a it's a so it's
it's it's nine hours nine hours that's
right it's n three units or n hours well
no but but I want it's a rigorous course
right so it's not it's not a it's
something where you'll really have a
chance to kind of dive into the models
and understand it and and look at the
code so thank you again everyone for uh
for joining us and as I see the last
question coming in yes the recording of
this uh of this presentation will be
sent out so if you miss something or you
want to watch it again or share it with
a colleague who might be interested in
this um you we will be sending that out
in about a week to everyone who
registered for the uh for the session
and again you can also send any
colleagues to the living matter lab to
learn more about this really interesting
topic so thank you Professor Co and
thank you everyone uh for joining us
today